hey folks welcome back to game sports
coverage of e3 2016 I'm very happy to be
joined by Toby from warhorse sir you
guys are responsible for one of the most
successful video game Kickstarter's
certainly one of the most discussed
while coming out of the Czech Republic
tell us about your game Kingdom Come
deliverance yeah thank you for inviting
me Kingdom Come deliverance is a
medieval RPG set in Bohemia in Central
Europe and we try to create a game that
is as realistic as possible and it's
historically accurate as possible so we
try to tell a story that actually really
happened in Central Europe and it said
that the life is telling the best story
so we are going this way and yeah that's
what we are working on and as you said
in we kickstart we were kick-started
funded in 2014 no we are on track so
it's kind of a Kickstarter success story
because this is happening final also you
asked what would you ask for like we was
around a quarter of a million and you're
not getting it we all wanted 300,000
British pounds right ask me how many now
then I $542 I think I say something like
that and we got that actually after 30
hours and after after 25 days we had 1.1
million British pounds and this was like
we well we were surprised of course we
thought that the people might like this
idea of course otherwise we wouldn't do
that but the good feedback we got even
from America Germany yeah was amazing so
yeah this has been a fascinating project
to sort of watch because the game that
you're creating is one that like I'm not
surprised you got that much backing
because it's a very sort of underserved
part of the video games market even
though you know the sort of like
realistic take on this like part of
history is really popular around the
world well yes it's well you are right
well and on the other hand no one did
did that before which is kind of if you
took if you look a lot a lot of RPGs
have have this medieval setting so you
have swords and kind of stuff but it's
always combined with dragons magic and
which I will well I like it I like The
Witcher like Skyrim I like those games
are awesome but we try to go another way
we try to go too we are try to want to
show the real medieval
setting so you have a landscape that
really exists that you have a castles
and churches and monasteries that really
existed back then we reconstructed them
all we have a 16 square kilometers map
of real landmass with Heights and
valleys and mountains and stuff we have
NPCs that really lived back then so
that's our reason that there are noble
persons then actually did something in
the world and in shape the future or
shaped our today's Europe so that's
really interesting and we're trying to
show that we want to show the people how
the medieval life looked like really
look like what topics that they cover
what problems that they have what
political struggle there was in Europe
maybe one of the first like real
national problems between Bohemia and
today's Germany right yeah that's that's
something we want to cover forgive me if
I'm wrong but you also have kind of like
a survival needs system with eating and
sleeping and any kind of exact stuff
like that exactly we have this as well
it's like it's not in a big extent but
there's a big part of it a small part of
it you have to eat and sleep in order to
stay healthy healthy you can take food
in your pockets of course but it will
spoil during time right yeah it's a fun
story I was fighting one time in due to
a presentation I was fighting and this
guy nearly killed me and I was wanted to
restore some energy and I had old had
only spoiled radish in my pocket so I
ate that poisoned myself and died of
really it's like it happens this game
comes across like almost like a medieval
armor or something where it's like it's
it's it's pushing so much into realism
that's it's just compelling that you
guys are creating this so like even is
there something like 16 different points
of the storage or clothing on your
character
exactly exactly it's kind of like this
you have an armor system you've got
horse armor as well here well it you it
works like that that you have a
different slot system we have it's it's
16 slots you can layer different parts
of armor over each other and every part
of armor or fabric or material is good
against another type of weapon attack
slashing stabbing something like this
and you have to combine it in a smart
way because for example a full plate
armor if you think about that it's a
full plate I'm a soldier something like
a medieval tank really right yeah and
with a sword you just can't
this guy you can smash him and smash him
stab him but the weapon the sword will
bounce off no think about the situation
take a mace crash him to death inside
his tin that's what you have to do and
with this layering system you are
physically really layering let's say a
soft gambeson a strong full plate and
with this you're customizing your armor
and that keeps your life because health
is nothing you can level in the in the
game and right yes the same amount of
energy health but it's the armor that
keeps you alive
and right as you said the armor is not
some strange number in your inventory
but we are calculating the physical
collision between your weapon and the
piece of armor rating ok so that's why
we have 16 slots makes an core horse you
can customize this however you want but
if you hit let's say if you are
completely naked and have only a full
plate helmet yeah Apple and I hit you
with my sword in the helmet you will
survive that but if I poke you in the
stomach you will die yeah that's what we
want to have in the game or that's what
we have in the game already so we have
we're only calculating the physical
collision between your weapon and the
piece of armor but it makes sense
because if you have a full plate armor
guy in front of you and he's not wearing
a helmet then where are you attacking of
course we had where us it's unprotected
and your shoes won't protect you from
hell spikes yeah sounds like we might be
dying a lot yeah and no well we want to
make it of course we want to make
one-hit kills of course you hit the head
but on the other hand it it's a game and
it's a fun game it's adds a big epic
story inside and we don't want to make
it so hard that it's like unplayable
anymore so there's of course the
compromise as I said as realistic as
possible but it's not a medieval
simulation but it's something that tries
to give you a good feeling about that
area and it has it compromises but of
course if you are bad if you have a bad
armor there's someone coming you will
die a lot of course so prepare so what
is the sort of moment-to-moment in terms
of like what is your do you play one
character is this all single-player do
you have quests is it open is it linear
well what are we talking about it we are
talking about an open-world RPG a
single-player open-world RPG where you
are playing a particular person called
Henry he's the son of a black
if his character is not a historical
person but the entire frame is but you
are playing a guy that lived is living
in a city which gets attacked by an
foreign King the king of Hungary and the
interesting part is that this really
happened so right this is something that
if you open the textbook it's really
there and you will the city gets
attacked your family get murdered the
city get destroyed everything happened
and you have to flee from this place
first you are driven by revenge you are
getting in the service of a noble who
gives your quests who who tells you what
to do who brings you back on the feed
but then you will first you're driven by
revenge as I said but first you realize
first you after you have after you
realized what is really going on is in
this place because there's a political
struggle you will have to pretty much
save Bohemia kind of but I'll be part of
it you are not saving like you're no
superhero that yeah you're just one of
many
so is there is a larger battles as well
well it's we want to show real medieval
life but it's also important to know
that large battles is something you
might know from lot of rings or
something for millions of soldiers this
is something not something that happened
really in back then and it wasn't even
happening now and like every weekend
right yes exactly we will have Castle
sieges for example that's a important
story a thing in the game but it was
something will be something like the
cherry on the cake or something yes so
if I could be happening really today is
a big moment let's say as super fast
sorry gone yeah you're better that's
what's going on I just want to say that
this is a monastery which is actually
really standing right now in Czech
Republic you can visit this place this
is really looking like that and the only
thing we had to do is we had to send our
team there take reference pictures of
all the stuff recreated and
reconstructed because it looks kind of
different today it was right draw it
partially but this church we are
standing in right now looks exactly like
wow with this pictures we have a full
time historian in our team we have a
painter in our team who's recreating
those buildings we want to show you the
real medieval experience how it really
looked like in Bohemia or Europe in the
15 fascinating stuff I the final thing
is sorry I the funny thing it was under
construction in 4103 so there's a
construction
oh man the same that's wonderful I those
monks didn't look like they were wearing
a lot of armor could you just if you
want to just stop one of that I'm
guessing it would be I got bad watch but
this is like an extreme important part
of the game you will have to you have to
investigate some guy who's hiding inside
this monastery and you the only thing
you know that he has a scar on his face
so but you have to go inside and find
this guy but there's no way how you
could enter a medieval monastery without
like getting kicked out hmm so you can
either sneak into the ninja game sneak
in during night but you have the
disadvantage that you cannot talk to
those guys because they will kick you
out you can well that's a brutal way but
you can just go in there and murder
everyone which is like one of them is
the right guy so well presumably quite
hard there will be a required and we
will have a great great impact a very
bad impact on your reputation for I want
to kill you people want to imprison you
will be everything you do in general in
the game will have some kind of proper
reaction so everything you do should
call you should face the consequences
but the third thing is actually what
you're what you said with the monks you
can actually enroll in this monastery
and become a monk something like a game
inside again already because you have to
get inside pretend that you actually
want to become a monk you won't do monk
duties be like praying several times a
day eating with them let's ask what a
monk Duty is just like we had an agent
actually because we wanted to have the
monastery but we had to research
Richards what research what they
actually did there mmm how often did
they pray how can we put quests inside
does it make sense to go there inside
was it possible so we have our crumpled
compromises we have our ideas but that's
what we want to show and here we fly it
away we flew away to a castle right now
so we are inside a noble place so our
painters strike again yeah right it this
everything is hand-painted by the way so
on one hand you have this epic story you
want to tell on the other hand us did as
far as I would say this epic visual so
it looks it should the big goal of
Kingdom Come deliverance is tell epic
story and raise the immersion bar to a
level that the rice and it's such a
thing because to be there well we have a
lot of game
that go back in history but they always
seem to you know sort of you know maybe
they have to because it types the game
they are they sort of toy with the
history they're playing in you know a
sorceress group is wonderful you go back
to Accra and Damascus and all these
places and that's awesome super
fascinating yeah and I grew up in a
medieval town in Ireland it's a thousand
years old and it like a lot of this sort
of stuff like reminds me of where I grew
up and I would love to have been able to
take it time-travel back that's what I
hear often that it looks when we have
forests for example some of you might
know our forests look well really good
as far as I would say but people are
actually telling us wow this is this
exactly looks like when I'm looking out
of my bag yeah it looks like a real
forest if you just do a screenshot it
looks like a picture and that's what we
want to achieve we want you give to give
you the illusion of a real living word
with an AI system which runs the world
where everything everyone has says daily
cycles everything is working somehow and
with the visuals that you look there and
say wow this is something I totally
believe yeah a lot of people in a chat
asking what platforms this is going to
be available on yeah we are working
right now on the PC version but of
course we are planning for ps4 and Xbox
one as well
so these three are the same platforms
and yeah that's something we want to
release in 2017
and here you can see rut I Castle that's
a castle that's also still existing in
Czech Republic it looks a bit different
but people need to understand that in
medieval times a castle was not a
Cinderella Castle or Minas Tirith or
something like this from Lord of the
Rings but this is how it really looked
like and this is how we want to transfer
it into the monitors yeah yeah if I sort
of functional it's like what do you mean
as in the castles they sort of yes now
we look at them as a tourist attraction
you know where it's like yeah obviously
much more than the castle is an
important place and you will even see it
because of the story you can't say I
want to see this castle because I am
bored or something yeah but it will be
connected to the story because if you
open the textbook it was really sieged
yeah that's wonderful stuff when will we
see Kingdom Come the lorentz I know you
guys been working on for years I think
there was an alpha for backers last year
he's like really we're a beta stage okay
we released the beta in March and we
want to release the final game next year
we don't have a precise date right now
but 2017 is our
this window right it's a nice big window
I like it Toby thank you so much for
coming on and showing like you're
Americans absolute pleasure we'll be
back in a couple of minutes folks the
folks from Eagle flight from Ubisoft
will be here in a second to show us off
one of their virtual reality games stay
there back in a minute you're watching
the GameSpot stage
brought to you by airheads